the spring 2022 anime season is coming
to a close with many a surprise both
welcome
and unwelcome
shield hero season 2 proved that the
promise neverland wasn't the only show
that could completely destroy the legacy
built by a great first season with a
gut-wrenchingly miserable second season
but on the other hand kagiasama's third
season rightfully took the throne at the
number one spot on my anime list
until the fullmetal alchemist resistance
force have their say that is proving
that no incredible anime stands a chance
against a good review bombing
and the highly anticipated spy family
yes it is pronounced spy family just how
hunter hunter is pronounced
well hunter hunter
and the highly anticipated spy family
reigns as not only one of the most
highly rated anime of the season but its
most popular as well
it's likely that not a single viewer
here has not seen the show yet or at
least felt the reverberations of its
effects rippling across social media
the numerous positive parts that were
produced out of the show's mass
popularity incredible cosplays fan arts
and such
seem to all be cursed by the law of
equivalent exchange as society's
deviance emerged from the descents of
their delinquency to clamp their claws
upon poor anya the young girl and focus
of much
misconduct
at the hand of the community as was
unfortunately expected to be fair
and if you have not yet witnessed any of
this
frankly
what are you doing
i mean this not to be demeaning nor
interrogative but more so a genuine
question on how you've managed to evade
one of the past couple years most
popular shows yet i suppose if you've
stumbled upon this humble video then you
can no longer make that claim as today i
will dive into not only the origins of
spy family but how it's managed to grasp
the love and admiration of so many souls
within the anime and manga community in
such a short time
come along with me and if you haven't
just watch spy family already
[Music]
tatia endo the creator of spy families
manga began his journey as an assistant
for other rather reputable shonen jump
manga blue exorcist and tatsuki
fujimoto's fire punch
building on this strong foundation and
his tutelage under quite successful
artists upon undertaking his own career
as a mangaka his initial one shots
formed a surprisingly extensive
collection of more mature stories that
stand in stark contrast to the comedic
backdrop of his latest breakout work
despite seeming polar opposites in tone
and topic alike after digging a little
deeper his last three one shots before
beginning spy family most notably
contain clear inspiration actually for
the series
anya's character design quite clearly
originated in the main character of
rengoku no ashey written to be a witch
with pink hair and horn-shaped ornaments
adorning her head
likewise endo claims that ishini usubeni
tatsuni hoshi was the first work to
inspire him to draw a small child's
character
which was very far out of his comfort
zone as a primarily seinen and dark
mangaka making him attribute this work
specifically to the reason he was even
able to write a young character like
anya in the first place later on
his last work before spy family i spy is
i mean i'm sure you can tell the
similarities here
upon the suggestion of his editor after
combining the best parts of these three
one shots and imbuing them with the
comedic basis that was missing from all
of his previous works something that the
editor believed could really turn around
the popularity of his writing endo
created spy family a series whose
initial reception among the editorial
department was supposedly so good that
its serialization was practically
decided before any proposals or meetings
were even extended an auspicious
foreboding for what was to come since
debuting in 2019 spy family has risen to
critical acclaim and cemented its place
in shonen jumps top 10 best-selling
manga in both years since
and it's safe to say that wit studio and
cloverworks adaptation of its anime is
following in the footsteps of that giant
but now that i've finished that chapter
of the lore it raises the question of
just what exactly elevates it to that
level
looking once again at the best-selling
shonen jump manga of last year spy
family is almost nothing alike its high
rolling compatriots
shonen jump has been experiencing a
transition into darker series for the
past couple years illustrated by the
front runner of the pack jujutsu kaisen
and the rising popularity of the work of
his former mentor tatsuki fujimoto's
huge cult-hit chainsaw man
spy family a romantic charming and
endearing comedy stands alone as a black
sheep
but perhaps that's exactly why it's so
great
spy family revolves around a spy named
twilight who must infiltrate into a
foreign country find a prominent yet
secretive politician and gather
intelligence on him in order to maintain
the safety of the entire world however
the only public outings this politician
attends to are at his son's school
exclusive to society's elite forcing
twilight to enlist the help of a young
girl anya and woman yore to act as his
pretend daughter and wife in order to
invade the politicians close circle
through this school and complete his
very dire mission
however unbeknownst to twilight the
seemingly tame civil servant yore
moonlights as an underground assassin
known as the thorn princess and the
strangely perceptive anya happens to be
an esper who can read minds
and this three-prong dynamic is the
source of the humor throughout spy
family as twilight yore and anja hide
their identities from each other
however anya actually knows from the
start exactly what everyone is hiding by
well reading their minds
because of this anya is arguably the
most fundamental factor that spy
families plot
story and comedy hinges upon restating
the importance of the character that
tatia endo has been crafting throughout
his works purposefully or not over the
span of almost the last decade of his
career
us viewers experience this family
vicariously through anya as she is aware
of other characters thoughts plans
things that normally only we would have
access to forming the dramatic irony of
the story
she shares those feelings with us
except through the special lens of a
child
more so than being jokingly manipulative
it is actually endearing to watch her
take advantage of her father's need to
complete his mission and obligation to
do anything for her to make sure she
does well in school
in moments of fear her cries to her mom
come across not as genuine panic for the
viewer but rather joy in seeing her
dependence on her mother who can and
will
annihilate anyone
the very serious jobs of spy and
assassin are twisted into the
perspective of a six-year-old child we
get to enjoy what anya sees as a
childlike fantasy rather than the
objectively strange and
quite precarious situation that it
really is
but interspersed among these moments of
hilarity
shine moments of real insight into the
heart of family as well
though twilight yore and anja are
created to be very different characters
defined by their rather extreme traits
or occupations they share one main
similarity
that they are alone
twilight lives a life of deception and
impermanence moving from mission to
mission and reminding himself to remain
detached always
yor though she has a brother is forced
to live a life of secrecy and crime for
the sake of both their well-being and to
maintain the facade on the outside
so as to not be suspected for her double
life
and anya a child out of a decrepit
orphanage and result of human
experimentation
has never had a real family
underneath this surface the comedy masks
the story of three lost souls finding
solace in one another
what initially begins as a strictly
professional agreement slowly develops
into a heartwarming realization of the
comfort that genuine relationships can
have for any of us
so whether you're watching spy family
for this or the humor or the occasional
action
it's a great show regardless
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video don't forget to like and subscribe
for future in-depth show manga and
character analyses
you